so what's going to happen in a recession  to the housing market  uh this recession i think is going to be  very small and very calm a recession  simply the economy is shrinking a little  two quarters in a row so what's that  mean to the housing market it means  housing market's probably gonna slow  down it's not gonna crash we're not  going into a depression  biden has not ruined the whole thing  it's not that fragile you're gonna be  okay but your house prices are not gonna  go down  they're just not gonna go up as fast  it's going to slow the market down just  like the higher interest rates and  mortgages are slowing the market down  and that's okay because the market was  quite hot